like i want to see units so you've been
to this house before right yeah i was in
the other studio
yeah yeah and the last time i was here i
announced the soup
oh that's right yeah yeah and now i'm on
here well let me preface this bite with
this okay
always played by the rules i went to
like church camp once because i
all the hot guys went and i was like i'm
in on this everybody drank the night
before and
a couple people got really sick and i
was scared so the next day when we had
confessionals
i told everybody that we drank
and everybody got in trouble and i was
like i thought that was the whole point
yeah yeah you play by the rules yeah you
know yeah yeah
then podcasts i i started a podcast with
redband at the very beginning it was
doing really well
and then i got manhattan love story and
they were like maybe not and i was like
okay you're right i shouldn't talk about
weed
like abc owns me yeah and then now
with the soup yeah it ended and they
were like maybe don't mention it but i
think that
for my own authenticity i need to okay
so
say it's in december it was done it's
done december
right and they called you they called me
and when they called you
were you surprised yeah well not
surprised because we hadn't heard
and i knew how difficult it was with the
covid and
i don't know what's really going on with
the network itself you know like so many
chain i know a lot of people got fired
so i was like oh [ __ ]
you can feel it when there's like a
shift of your you know your whole
universe
like i kind of felt like as soon as they
called me midday like
a bunch of them on the phone i was like
either like i booked something
or yeah yeah it's done if you guys
aren't in the end you know that you get
this phone call like hey hey we got mark
on the phone we got jen in there oh yeah
yeah i had one last week i had one of
those where
all of a sudden all of a sudden
everybody needs to get on zoom right now
ugh but that's good i don't know so when
they everyone got on so there's like 19
boxes
right of just that's your team yeah and
i'm looking at every box to see what
their
reaction is and some of them are like
you know i mean some of them are
you know me so you don't know yeah and
the mid the news was um
lukewarm yeah kinda but it's like so
but they're the worst calls to get
where's call yeah it was the worst cause
you know
i put it it meant a lot to me to have a
vehicle to
finally get to be free and like
basically i wasn't
you know what i mean it was so noted and
it like there was so much weight on it
for me to be a certain way
and they like i mean i had to do like
teleprompter classes
when i had already been doing this for
you know like they just wanted to like
know that they could rely on it yeah and
it made me kind of a robot on it
yeah you know and like i was watching
episodes the other day i was like
i'm not really like my free self on it
and it's such a bummer
that i didn't get to make it and you
might really
fight because you don't really
i can only imagine if i was on a show
like that right and
if if i was new on the show right you
can't really
fight for your own voice when you they
don't know what the numbers are no i'm
trying to make them happy
yeah second season you know i'm i play
the game and i'm going to do everything
they tell me to do and it was an
awesome experience i mean i learned so
much yeah but also i learned like
yeah like maybe like go with your gut a
little more
yeah but yeah it's a bummer it's done
and it's
it's time for the next the next chapter
um but i was telling you earlier jade i
i i
honestly i just um i have to say
that um i'm not really that worried
about it
yeah oh thanks that makes me feel good
because it's like you look at
like someone like sarah silverman okay
and she just will always
work she will always you know
have an audience um she has her voice
and you know she's just a great just a
nice lady you know
no she's the best she's the best and um
i feel that same about you it's like i
just they feel like it's
you know you're always gonna work you're
not one of those like
because i know those i've seen i've met
them i've seen them i've seen people
like
are around for like three years and you
just know
in your gut that they're just gonna be
gone isn't that weird you like you're
kind of on this path and people are like
huh and then they like kind of just like
you just pass them by like they just
drop out like flies you know
yeah no i'm ready i'm ready for the
night because of the they can't handle
the pain and suffering oh it's so much
pain
and it feels so good i know but if
there's it
and it's like i'm not saying that you
know people in show business have it
like
harder than anybody else i'm not saying
that and we chose it too which is yeah
like we're doing this we chose to be in
in this insane thing
and it's like i was i was with my
therapist yesterday and i was like
complaining about something
and she's like stop it because you chose
to be here
no one's forcing you to do this business
you're the you're the one
you're mean well it's because that's
exactly what i've been saying to him for
years but i
love that he's in therapy now so she is
basically just
validating all the things i've said like
no one has a gun to your head
yeah no one has a [ __ ] gun this is a
hundred percent
your choice so you either you take the
good with the bad
so hard [ __ ] keep moving yeah it's
funny because i want to imagine like
that she's on an earpiece to your
therapist
[Laughter]
that's our couple sessions honestly our
couple sessions are my favorite